hello i am dr umar malik and welcome to
mad simplified
the superfood that we are going to talk
about this sunday is moringa and its
amazing health benefits
it is also known as the miracle tree or
the radish tree because of the numerous
health elements it contains
moringa is a plant native to india nepal
and they're joining southeast asian
countries
and has been used since centuries for
its numerous health benefits
it has anti-inflammatory properties
antioxidant properties it contains
abundant varieties of different vitamins
and nutrients and it also has very good
amounts of protein in it it also has
pain relieving properties
moringa has been used for asthma
diabetes cardiovascular diseases
breastfeeding problems and many other
purposes like for improving digestion
improving decreased libido and immunity
it can also be grown cheaply and easily
and retains much of its nutritional
value when it is dried
it is most commonly consumed in a powder
form and can be added to many dishes and
it is also been used as a tea
we will talk about several ways and
about how you can incorporate moringa
plant in your diet in the end of this
video so make sure to watch the video
till the very end
so without further ado let's begin and
we'll talk about the five amazing health
benefits of moringa plant
number one moringa is packed with
vitamins and minerals
the leaves of moringa plant contain more
vitamin c than the same amount of
oranges
this gives moringa its antioxidant and
anti-inflammatory properties
one cup of chopped leaves is considered
a good source of iron calcium vitamin c
vitamin b6 and riboflavin and has
notable amounts of potassium vitamin a
vitamin e and magnesium
that means moringa can contribute to
everything from better vision and
immunity to bone health and skin
radiance
number two pouring a plant has abundant
amounts of protein
the powder made from the leaves and
branches of the moringa plant contain
abundant amounts of protein
although there are many vegetarian
sources of protein like soy tofu and
oats what's special about moringa
protein is that it is a complete source
of protein meaning it contains all 20
essential amino acids as compared to
many other sources of plant protein
which contains incomplete proteins these
incomplete proteins lack one or other
essential amino acids that cannot be
produced by our body so in that case the
protein present in the moringa plant is
very good for our body powders made from
its crushed leaves are packed with
almost three grams of protein per
tablespoon
number three moringa is good for your
liver health
free radicals are created in our body by
things like pollution fried food sun
exposure drug intake and many other
harmful activities going on in our body
the damage our body by causing oxidative
stress cell damage and premature aging
this damage is especially prominent in
our liver as it is most active site in
our body for the waste removal and free
radical
metabolism the moringa plant contains
abundant antioxidants like flavonoids
polyphenols and ascorbic acid that can
help to reduce the damage that is done
by the free radicals
this promotes liver health and a diet
rich in antioxidants has been shown to
prevent premature aging and wrinkles on
the skin
number four moringa is good for people
with diabetes
moringa helps to reduce the amount of
glucose levels in the blood as well as
the sugar and protein levels in the
urine
spikes in the insulin and blood sugar
levels can lead to development of type 2
diabetes and obesity
according to a scientific study moringa
leaf powder extract has been effective
in reducing the lipid and glucose levels
in patients with diabetes
one clinical study also proved the
therapeutic antioxidant properties of
moringa as well as the lower fasting
glucose levels in post-menopausal women
who took a supplement with moringa and
amaranth leaves for three months
one animal study even showed that the
moringa in the diet could help to reduce
weight gain and insulin resistance
so all this evidence shows that moringa
plant is very good for people with
diabetes and obesity as well
number five moringa is good for
digestion
moringa leaf powder contains about 30
fiber most of it is insoluble which is
very good for digestion and prevention
of constipation
moringa is a natural antibiotic and
antibacterial agent and may help in the
inhibition of growth of various
pathogens that can cause digestive upset
those who suffer from constipation
bloating gas gastritis and ulcerative
colitis should add moringa leaves to
their diet
the leaves have antibiotic and
antimicrobial properties which make them
an ideal remedy against digestive
disorders and the high amount of b
vitamins in the leaves help in improving
the digestion
you can click on this video which is
showing on your screen right now this
video will guide you as to how you can
prepare moringa powder extract and
incorporate it into your diet
so thank you for watching if you found
this video helpful please support our
channel by pressing the like button on
this video and by sharing this video
with your friends and family you can
also support us by becoming a member of
our patreon group all the links are
given in the description box down below
goodbye and i'll see you in the next
video